okay now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to walk you through what you need
to be able to work out a whole series of
areas okay I'm going to give you six
formulas of this see it's two of them
the two trickier ones the two reader
ones are on your formula and data sheet
which leaves behind that you need to
actually remember now thankfully they're
the four that are really quite
straightforward but what's important to
me in this lesson is not that you see
you know what the equations are and know
that they're right but that the
equations the form is actually feel
right to you that you get a vibe for ah
it's not just a random jumble of letters
and numbers like say yeah okay that make
sense
so here's where we're gonna begin the
first diagram we're gonna draw a
rectangle so when you have a rectangle
that's a strong one here sorry when you
have a rectangle right I'm really need
two legs in a rectangle and we tend to
call them and okay I've labeled as a
right angle so it's writing by the way
you know how what makes a rectangle
rectangle is that it's got um right
angles everywhere that in fact is
exactly what rectangle means for example
if you say like a to you there's a
picture on the wall and it's kind of
wonky and you say can you rectify that
for me what you mean is can you make it
right okay
or if there's an arrow making like it's
literally that's where we get the word
from right so rectangle means writing
okay um now what do I do if I want to
work out the area of this shape if I
know the breadth and the height I just
multiply that's it so remember I said
there are four to remember true they get
handed to you well this is one and it's
pretty easy and you were all able to
recall it just like that okay next one
is a parallelogram so again let's draw a
diagram and let's make sure it's leaning
over so you can really tell it's a
parallelogram
yeah sorry I'll fix it just give you
something I mean it's okay no it's
because I wasn't standing straight onto
the whiteboard when I did it that's why
okay now what am I do he is will be
really really helpful if you have excuse
me you can see I'm using a couple of
columns here I'm gonna use a third one
in a second now on a parallelogram we
also have a B and an H but they refer to
something slightly different said the B
we usually call this face I mean it
looks like it's in the same spot but
recording in a base rather than just how
it is
because if I if I asked you how broad
that's what breadth leaders come what is
this parallelogram you'd probably go all
the way from here to there if there's
not actually what I want and I just want
this side okay H also stands for
something different so instead of just
like one of the sides you actually need
to add in a perpendicular line right so
this height er it's actually an
abbreviation for the perpendicular
height right it's like measured in a
right angle that's how tall the thing is
it's just convenient that because a
rectangle has writing it everywhere the
hi it's just over yet but in a
parallelogram
you're not the case okay so why don't
what you see now it's time to get you on
the Colorado is if you do a slight legal
rearrangement here this parallelogram I
want to try and change it so it looks
like a rectangle okay so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna slice off this little
triangle bit key okay if I slice that
bit off remembering that what makes a
parallelogram a parallelogram is these
parallel sides I should be able to grab
this part here they're trying to
I should be able to grab it cut it off
and move it over to the right it's time
to pair them in there what is okay now
if I've done that right and this is all
right angles and all that jazz then
having lost the red triangle for a man
and put it over here this shape now is
just a rectangle just like before so in
fact the formula for the area of a
parallelogram is exactly the same right
when when you know it when you know that
here they're lengths of these sides
right here the important thing is this H
is not a side it's like it's like the
leaning over side it's gonna be how
provinces all right sir
I said there one remember two of them
are identical so this is not so hard
the next one is you want to give me a
suggestion okay now we'll get to a
trapeze new treaty it's actually one of
the trickier ones I want to I want a
simpler shape what's a simple shape I
still haven't got on his okay so I can
think about the square but this is just
a kind of rectangle so I'm lining it up
I think I heard someone say triangles
now let's draw a triangle and trying to
make it too nice and neat like as you
not like perfect an isosceles triangle
or something like that
here's my triangle and just like with
the parallelogram I'm gonna put a base
and a perpendicular height one so I'm
gonna call this bottom edge the base
yeah it's a lot of salt and what's
really cool it's about time you got so
about did you hear about how what's that
country if you put all those solar
panels in the Sahara Desert
Wow nice breeze now you know who really
knows Han Solo um four people in this
class Germans they really know that's
here in fact I've got a friend and he's
going into photovoltaics he's an
engineer and I'm he's moving to Germany
because all of the legit stuff in solar
is happiness
in fact I think they have so much
renewable energy one day recently they
had to pay their citizens to use power
because they had so much been generated
by anyway yeah yeah it's amazing
why don't we have that Australian felt
like really possible okay now where were
we I put a base on I will show you this
perpendicularly so I can have a
perpendicular height okay now then the
question becomes well how do I ignore
like some of you may well be able to
quote may be able to quite the format in
which is great but if you remember I
said to you I want more than just for
you to know the formulas
I'm gonna say right I want you to feel
that they make sense okay so here's what
I'm gonna do
again you can't I want to relate the
triangle to the shapes I already know
about okay so what I'm gonna do is take
this triangle and I'm going to encase it
in a rectangle so I'm going to draw
around it like this okay so you can see
I put a box around my triangle okay now
what's great about this box is that
because of the way I brought us it has
the same bread for the base of the
breadth of the same it has the same
height it's all looks just like this one
in fact the dimensions embracing me too
what's brilliant about this is and I'm
sorry if you want site to run out of
colors now line up this will make it
cool I've never got not one triangle but
in fact because of all the lines I've
got I have four trainers for triangles
right watch see about this left-hand
part of my original triangle but do you
notice that that pilot triangle exactly
matches to this park here can you see
that like they're literally that where
the fancy where we use is congruent okay
so those two triangles are coming
they're the same size okay
in exactly the same way you look at the
right hand side and this triangle here
it also has a twin right this part on
the outside that I added by making only
the rectangle yeah
so now tell me what's the area of the
rectangle I think it's it spread much
higher okay so that's why this is not
just some magical coincidence it's
because the way we work out trends is
it's exactly half of a rectangle is it
making sense for you right